bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
l'audition de deux représentants du
conseil allemand des experts économiques
un organisme indépendant qui conseille
les décideurs allemands qui analyse
également les politiques économiques de
l'allemagne mais aussi de l'ensemble de
l'europe alors ces deux représentants
ont été auditionnés par les sénateurs
dans le cadre d'une mission qui a pour
objectif d'établir la réalité de
l'impact sur l'emploi de l'exonération
de charges sur les salaires lors la
france et l'allemagne sont très souvent
comparé d'un point de vue économique
l'allemagne est le premier partenaire
économique de la france et si les deux
pays ont eu à faire face aux mêmes
problèmes l'insertion sur le marché du
travail de travailleurs peu qualifiés
ces deux pays ont su des choix
radicalement différent
pour en savoir plus tout de suite retour
à cette audition qui s'est tenu cette
semaine au sénat
je souhaite donc la bienvenue
à monsieur benjamin weger tu es à
monsieur markus clem
monsieur vega et secrétaire général
et monsieur markus clem et économistes
sont tous deux donc du conseil allemand
des experts économiques
je rappellerai à l'attention de mes
collègues que
le conseil des experts économiques a été
installée en 1963 il s'agit d'un
organisme indépendant composé de cinq
membres nommés pour cinq ans par le
président fédéral sur proposition du
gouvernement et qui a pour mission de
conseiller les décideurs sur les
questions de politique économique c'est
un organe respecté et écouté qui est
appuyé par une équipe d'experts
dirigée par le secrétaire général
monsieur vague art que nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir donc aujourd'hui et
qui est accompagné de monsieur klein
comme je vous le dit qui est spécialiste
des politiques du marché du travail et
au fil de nos auditions donc notre
mission qui a pour but de vérifier ou
d'heures
d'établir les réalités de l'impact du
des exonérations de charges sociales sur
les salaires sur l'emploi lui-même
il a été souvent question de l'allemagne
notre premier partenaire économique et
notre premier point de comparaison
confronté à la même difficulté celle de
l'insertion des travailleurs peu
qualifiés sur le marché du travail
l'allemagne a fait des choix très
différents des nôtres avec une forte
différenciation entre l'industrie et les
services et la pratique d'une forte
modération salariale
les modes de financement de la
protection sociale sont aussi très
différent
progressif en france ils sont dégressifs
en allemagne
nous avons nous avons demandé messieurs
de bien vouloir nous présenter les
politiques menées en allemagne ces
dernières années mais aussi de nous
faire part des objectifs
assignés aux évolutions récentes en
particulier
l'un traduit l'introduction d'un salaire
minimum défini au niveau fédéral
enfin le dernier rapport annuel du
conseil des experts économiques de
novembre 2013
dont je traduirai assez librement le
titre par contre une politique
économique tournée vers le passé
comporte un chapitre sur le travail en
europe il me semble intéressant que nous
fassiez part de votre regard sur notre
politique
alors ces questions pour but de vous
permettre de nous faire un exposé
liminaire et ensuite madame rapporteur
madame michèle demessine vous vous
posera ses propres questions et ensuite
nos nos collègues interviendront donc si
vous voulez vous avez un moment pour
nous présenter et nous on nous répond
dans ces quelques questions introductive
je vous remercie
il ya fils d'adrien danse veut dire
merci beaucoup de cette invitation il de
la possibilité que vous nous donnez de
prendre la parole aujourd'hui de vous
devant vous de vous exposer le point de
vue de l'allemagne de manière
transparente
d'autre part cela nous permet également
de dire ce qui a fait que nous avons
entrepris ses réformes à l'époque
pourquoi on le début des années 2000
voire au début des années 1990
l'allemagne s'est engagée sur la voie de
certaines réformes
je me suis demandé aux interprètes si
jamais ils ne parlent pas trop vite et
nous suivons
de votre
exposé vise avait donné tout avant le
contexte général pour comprendre comment
le système allemand a conçu et aménagé
quels ont été les réformes entreprises
quels étaient les objectifs de
la deuxième partie monsieur clem et vous
exposera
son garage
point de vue d'aujourd'hui à savoir
avons nous atteint les objectifs ou non
quelles ont été les difficultés
rencontrer et quels ont été les
corrections les calmes
comme l'a dit nous sommes une
institution indépendante et c'est pour
cela que notre dernier rapport de
l'année dernière est très critique et ne
correspond pas forcément à l'avis
officiel du gouvernement nous sommes un
institut indépendant qui regarde ce qui
se passe dans le monde économique avec
un oeil critique
et qui informe l'opinion publique
j'aimerais attirer l'attention sur le
fait que le
conseil de dix experts économiques a
déjà
surveiller de près si réforme dès les
années 2000 a annoncé des avertissements
en dix ans que d'euros en 2012 notre
conseil a émis un rapport qui s'appelait
20 points sur la politique de l'emploi
et que six mois plus tard il y avait
l'agenda 2010 qui était senti qu'il
s'attelait 2010 parce qu'en fait on
n'avait retenu que d'y passer
la blague qu'il courait en allemagne à
cette époque maintenant pourquoi
avons-nous entrepris ses réformes
futures offrant
le nom de guerre dans les années 1990
l'allemagne était considéré comme
l'homme malade de l'europe aujourd'hui
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des raisons c'est
tellement pour lesquels nous nous sommes
appliqués aujourd'hui à prendre la
parole devant vous on est un peu étonné
de ce qui se passe sur le marché
allemand de l'emploi comment ce passe
t'il que nour a continué à avoir une
bonne politique d'emploi sur le marché
allemand damoclès que s'est noyé aux
réformes malgré donc la crise alors ce
qui a été déterminant pour les réformes
en allemagne a été mon coeur nous avions
tous de chômage très haut historique
vous voyez ici le taux de chômage qui
en 1972 on avait quasiment le plein
d'emplois en allemagne
évolution
du taux de chômage en allemagne a été de
quelques secondes à
denis chalifoux
à chaque fois on a ri avec c'était en
fait mon évolution d'escalier au
fait que l'on à une progression
constante du taux de chômage à
un niveau très élevé sont que des
allocations nécessaires au niveau du
budget de l'état d'esprit on me
reprendre
les discussions allaient dans la même
direction et celle que vous avez déjà
esquissé à savoir comment financer cela
s'il n'arrive pas à réduire
ne faut-il pas à les diminuer
significativement le taux de chômage
pour pouvoir diminuer également le
financement de l'aide en aide si
nécessaire
donc c'était l'une des réflexions en
même temps l'allemagne a vécu un gros
chèque
une offre économique avec la
réunification de l'allemande au détour
des années 90 début des années 2000 qui
a vraiment lourdement pesé sur le budget
de l'état au scotch longue date le
niveau d'autant plus quand elle même de
mentionner allemagne de l'est où on n'a
pas le même de votre salaire et que d'un
seul coup on a essayé d'avoir le même
niveau de salaire de ce fait il ya
beaucoup d'emplois qui n'ont pas pu être
maintenu une fois que
les salaires étaient presque 50% plus
élevé en allemagne de l'ouest à l'époque
qu'en allemagne de l'est et de ce fait
les systèmes
d'assurance
chômage sont en tenant une pression
extrême c'est extrêmement mentation des
salaires
beaucoup
compétitivité de l'allemagne
avec le deutsche mark mais j'aimerais
quand même souligner aussi les
entreprises ont déjà pris elle même
démesure c'est à dire que les réformes
ne visait pas l'amélioration de la
compétitivité de l'allemagne mais à
augmenter la croissance
et à permettre de plus en plus de
personnes ont participé au marché du
travail pour pouvoir se nourrir elle
même pour pouvoir elle même soutenir
leur famille donc il ne s'agissait pas
en forme
rendre les entreprises plus compétitives
sur le marché international je crois que
nous avons eu des taux très élevés et
court jusqu'au 13 ans b avec le chômage
dans le même temps
nous avons donc entrepris une
vaste réforme
il y a eu un débat public à l'époque
nous dépose chez les 5 millions de
chômeurs
et
taux de chômage fortement élevé ce seuil
de 5 millions rappelait fortement
l'époque
hitler avait pris le pouvoir en raison
justement du taux de chômage très élevé
sur lequel il avait beaucoup joué
donc c'était psychologiquement un seuil
très difficile à supporter on se disait
non on ne veut plus avoir 5 millions de
chômeurs en allemagne salman
butt que s'est-il passé sur le marché du
travail
certaines choses se sont passées sans
que l'état n'intervienne c'est ce que
nous appelons des changements endogène
les parties prenantes aux conventions
collectives aussi bien du côté patronal
que du côté des salariés
vraiment décidé de retrouver de la
compétitivité on travaille on sent le
revers de la médaille et cela c'est lié
aux institutions du marché de vente en
allemagne sur lesquelles je reviendrai à
l'époque donc non une fête a été que
l'on a perçu donc cette augmentation
constante du chômage toujours avec les
mêmes soupe de à problème à savoir les
personnes moins qualifiées les personnes
plus âgées
il y en a même personne des personnes
qui étaient exclus du marché du jeu du
travail les entreprises ont fait ce
qu'elle pouvait pour rester compétitif
ce n'était pas le problème le problème
c'était que nos systèmes sociaux étaient
organisées de telle manière que de plus
en plus de personnes les ont intégrés
ont bénéficié des coûts des prestations
sociales
et donc on a commencé à voir ses
réformes notamment à partir de 2001 avec
le l'emploi à temps partiel et ensuite
avec les grandes réformes appelé arsène
et ce n'était pas une seule réforme
on parle maintenant on est au niveau de
hartz iv
c'était de vastes réformes qu'elle est
bien plus loin que cela cela comprenait
vraiment l'ensemble des institutions
présentes sur le marché de l'emploi
et qui était directeur lien avec une
guitare il y a eu d'autres mesures
politiques qui ont été prises la fin des
années 1990
au fond il ya une réforme de l'assurance
retraite et une réforme fiscale
pour les entreprises notre activité
pour
améliorer l'attrait des investissements
dans les entreprises en allemagne
quel était l'objectif des réformes dit
alors si ça
enfin mutt lange les objectifs
que l'on améliore la possibilité de
placer des personnes sur le marché de
l'emprunt
donc que l'on est meilleur
l'employabilité si elle était
relativement faible à cette époque
correspond
l'un des points de départ de la réforme
en 2003 donc on a eu cette grande
réforme a en fait c'était lié à un grand
scandale de l' agence nationale de
l'emploi fait l'équivalent allemand
tabou de sa gamme tough arbeit
sa maintenance
d'une société qui s'occupe et donc du
chômage et de l'assurance chômage et on
s'est aperçu que 70%
à 10 ans
emploi-pro curé était faux en fait il
n'avait pas été
donner à des personnes les chiffres
donc mis en place une commission la
commission
qui devait élaborer des propositions
pour voir comment les institutions
publiques travaillant sur le marché de
l'emploi pouvait être changée modifier
l'objectif des coûts tels que le
processus que l'on appelle de matching
c'est-à-dire
d'améliorer l'employabilité
parce qu'on avait un vrai déficit
dans
dans la manière dont travaillaient les
institutions étatiques des agences
nationales de l'emploi
donc les propositions élaborées au sein
de la commission hard
drive grosse
se traduisait notre passion politique il
y avait donc nos l'employabilité d'un
côté ça s'était très nettement
vraiment les institutions publiques
c'est-à-dire l'équivalent de l'agencé
nationale pour l'emploi qui devaient
être entièrement réformé ensuite il
fallait stimuler la demande
et en même temps
améliorer l'offre de travail à savoir
vérifier
idrissa n'a
fait que
toutes les toutes les primes pourra
intéresser quelqu'un
fait
d'irrégulier on a régularisé l'occident
de travail savoir une strie même journée
on ne le considérons comme un instrument
flexible pour les entreprises
j'ai
trouvé ce qu'ils n'ont besoin que de
personnel temporaire donc qui ont besoin
d'un certain tampon on va dire de mal de
oeuvre ensuite il y avait hearts 2 là il
s'agissait
de l'adoration des mini jobs ceux des
emplois moins de francs qui n'ont aucune
qui sont entièrement exonéré de charges
sociales pour le patron et puis ensuite
il y allait en milieu rural de 400 à 800
heureux parce que les minutes ch
publique inférieure à 400 euros et
maintenant on est d'ailleurs un seuil
pour les yéniches
450 à 850 euros mais je donne tout ce
qu'il a il y à une exonération partielle
des charges sociales malgré tout les
employeurs doivent payer des forfaits de
charges sociales de
25% à peu près du salaire enfin de 25%
des
finances y allons tout son sens et puis
il ya également un soutien financier
pour les professions libérales qui a été
introduit et enfin le coeur de la
réforme a été de 3 savoir la
restructuration la réorganisation de les
agences pour l'emploi on donne à ma
fille et ensuite
4 je prie on en parle régulièrement cite
en exemple ces traits forme et c'est la
raison pour laquelle
tout marche aussi bien en allemagne
maintenant
c'est ce qui se dit mais je ne dirais
pas de manière aussi généraliser mais
j'aimerais quand même
montrer ce que nous avons fait
avec celle 4 nous avons diminué le
niveau social quand on dit cela en fait
on oublie certaines choses et j'aimerais
illustrer ce point du groupe des vingt
deux ans
que l'on puisse se remettre rapidement
les personnes sur le marché du travail
et je vais vous montrer le système que
nous avons réorganisé le tous s'étaient
alors massés nous présenter de manière
on va dire stérile c'est à dire plus
digeste plus digeste parce que c'était
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça alors
mine à l'assurance chômage qui protège
du chômage et qui paie en fonction du
statut familial
si on est célibataire sur les
mariés sont une famille on paye
63 et 67 % du salaire net après
déduction de tous les frais sociaux et
impôts mais cela ne peut être n'était
pendant trente deux mois
ensuite il y avait une nouvelle
assurance qui intervenait c'était
l'assurance chômage longue durée
cette
femme était associé à aucun examen
nécessité s'il s'agissait
donc d'un montant de 53 57 % du dernier
salaire net pendant trente deux mois on
ne touchait une assurance chômage et en
suite on passait à l'assurance d'une
longue chômage longue durée aux
autoroutes
a2 et il y avait en dessous encore donc
l'aide sociale l'aide sociale c'est ce
que l'on appelle un peu une assurance de
base autour de spots houle vraiment là
il s'agit de nécessité c'est ce que nous
avons réformer ce système alors qu'avant
nous sommes en allemagne
l'assurance-chômage
savoir le tellement pour assurer un
paiement correspondant à peu près au
niveau de vie précédent a été diminuée
si non nous n'avons rien changer au
système on à en diminuer les durs et
maintenant il s'agit d'un maximum de 24
mois mais ses 24 ans -
concerne les salariés plus âgés à partir
de
58 ans
parce que ce que nous avons également
fait ça c'est la réforme vraiment hartz
iv ce que nous avons fait c'est de
réformer l'assurance chômage longue
durée
mettez un médecin dans ce giro parce que
nous l'avons assorti d'un flash mob d'un
examen de la nécessité c'est à dire il
fallait vraiment couvrir les besoins
tant qu'on a éliminé en couronne second
cette assurance chômage longue durée et
on a introduit une
garantie non
qui permettait un peu de couvrir les
besoins mais elle était plutôt plus
élevé que l'ancienne aide sociale en
même temps moins élevée que l'an ciel
être chômage longue durée
l'assurance chômage longue durée
sans réponse de faim quand on était
couvert par ce système quand vous étiez
une couverts par le système d'assurance
chômage longue durée et que vous toucher
cette allocation chômage ou la toucher
tout le temps on ne sortait pas de ce
système la seule chose qui pouvait nous
arriver c'est que nous
les laissons mentation de salaires
augmentaient donc l'aide sociale
augmenter pendant qu'on stagne et d'un
autre côté mais voilà en gros ce qui se
passait et donc on le voit maintenant
sur le profil ce que l'on voulait
c'était admis lloret la rapidité de mise
sur le marché de l'emploi jeunes à la
bio parce que les personnes retrouvent
rapidement un emploi
il est probable qu'ils vont s'installer
dans la durée dans le chômage
il s'agissait vraiment disposition sly
stone age pression est
donc de faciliter cette remise sur le
marché de l'emploi des chômeurs
cette
modestie
dans le même temps
groupe
ares est en dessous on a augmenté la
pression sur les personnes bénéficiant
également de d'allocations chômage
ne pouvais plus refuser un travail mon
sens autre raison valable
ce que l'on appelle l'allocation chômage
2 donc de la réforme son art 6 4 on ne
peut pas refuser n'importe quel travail
après trois mois de chômage du ring je
traînais les règles deviennent de
puissants plus dur
qui vise à faire en sorte que le chômeur
reviennent sur le marché
donc il faut être prêt à accepter une
baisse de salaire quand on nous fait une
offre de travail on ne peut plus avoir
la prestation d'avoir un maintien de
salaire
on retrouve en un nouvel emploi
non sentra la pompe un peu je m'appelle
essentielle et j'en arrive à la fin de
ce bref
de cette brève rétrospective sur les
raisons pour lesquelles nous avons
entrepris ces réformes avant de passer
la parole à monsieur klein sur les
impacts de ces réformes mais toutes ces
réformes ont été évalués la décision
était indexée à des évaluations
donc il était clair que l'on voulait
avoir donc des évaluations et beaucoup
de choses qui ont été
introduites à l'époque n'ont cessé
d'être modifiés parce qu'au fil des
évaluations on s'est aperçu que certains
objectifs n'avaient pas été atteints ou
comme on avait pu le voir sur atteint
certains objectifs donc sans cesse on
assure réaménager cette réforme pour
améliorer leur efficacité
et cela continue bien sûr l'ensemble des
mesures le catalogue de mesures de la
politique active de l'emploi est soumis
à une évaluation permanente pour pouvoir
améliorer les instruments de cette
politique et
n'avoir au final que des instruments
efficaces
c'était un élément essentiel cette
réforme à savoir il ya maintenant une
évaluation scientifique continue je
passe la parole à mon collègue
tout d'abord je voudrais à mon tour vous
remercier de votre invitation de nous
donner l'occasion de présenter le marché
du travail allemand j'essaye donc
désormais de vous présenter de façon
plus concrètement les développements sur
le marché du travail allemand depuis
2005 nous avons vu
au début que l'allemagne est désormais
dans une position bien meilleure qu'au
début des années 2000
et pour revenir sur le graphique de tout
à l'heure cela se complique un petit peu
maintenant tout à l'heure nos avions les
lignes rouges qui se sont arrêtés en
2005 pour montrer on est les
développements du chômage depuis il ya
eu donc une grosse pression par rapport
à la mise en place de réformes nous
observons donc que depuis 2005 le
développement du chômage s'est
considérablement
diminué a considérablement diminué et ce
qui nous vaut maintenant
et ce qui est en vérité presque une
preuve pour dire que les réformes ils
sont vraiment pour quelque chose
pour la toute première fois nous pouvons
constater un nombre le nombre de la
population active augmente en tout en
ayant des taux de chômage qui descendent
jusqu'à maintenant nous n'avions pas pu
observer ce type de développement donc
il n'y avait pas de corrélation entre
l'augmentation des personnes
actives et la diminution du chômage nous
avons ici aussi l'aller bleu qui indique
le chômage structurel qui est également
en baisse depuis 2005
c'est donc très concrètement une d un
des succès de ses réformes pour le
marché du travail en allemagne il ya
d'autres facteurs mais son état
il y a par ailleurs les processus du
marché assez spécifique à l'allemagne du
fait que nous ayons les partenaires
sociaux qui conviennent des conventions
collectives
c'est parties prenantes agissent
également en tant que facteur sur cette
évolution et d'une façon générale
l'évolution économique dans le monde où
nous a facilité un peu les choses afin
de
mettre en place plus de réformes dans un
pays comme l'allemagne qui exporte
beaucoup
monsieur wenger a déjà fait allusion à
notre mandat
d'être indépendant avec nos critiques
nous avons donc mis en place des
évaluations macroéconomiques et
microéconomiques afin de mesurer les
effets de ce type de réforme pour savoir
s'il faut appuyer certaines mesures ou
au contraire lever un peu le pied sur
certains autres
ce n'est pas toujours évident de savoir
évaluer l'évolution
au niveau macro économique en
particulier c'est un peu plus compliqué
néanmoins les études qui existent
jusqu'à aujourd'hui indique que ces
réformes sont en bonne partie
responsables
de l'évolution actuelle et qui contribue
à améliorer la situation sur le marché
du travail
donc les réformes de hearts 1 à hearts
iii qui visait à améliorer là on va dire
la convergence entre le nombre personnes
cherchant un emploi et les emplois
disponibles qui étaient gérés par les
les agence fédérale pour l'emploi nous
voyons ici
l'évolution des courbes et l'évolution
entre le nombre de postes disponibles et
le nombre de personnes nombre de
chercheurs d'emploi
on observe facilement que lors d'une
faible conjoncture économique le taux de
chômage décembre et lors d'une meilleure
évolution économique le taux de chômage
diminue on peut donc se poser la
question
à quel point le processus de faire
rencontrer les chercheurs d'emploi les
postes disponibles fonctionne ou non
c'était la question cruciale qui que
nous nous sommes posée à la fin des
années 90 début des années 2000 nous
avons depuis réussi à améliorer cette
courbe puisque nous observons que avec
le même nombre de postes disponibles
nous constatons que le nombre de
recherches de demandeurs d'emploi
diminuent monsieur bikers également
évoqué que la raison de mettre en place
cette commission art était le scandale
qui concerne l agence fédérale pour
l'emploi en allemagne du fait que
pratiquement 70 % des demandeurs
d'emploi n'ont pas pu être
transfert n'ont pas pu être recommandée
pour les postes pourtant disponibles on
peut éventuellement si on peut dire
ce qu on étiquette ce conte ce à quoi on
de l'étiquette avec hartz iv et quelque
chose comme la modernisation de la loi
pour
les nouvelles conditions du marché du
travail pour le dire de façon quasi mot
à mot au centre de
l'intérêt était de décentraliser les
processus
il fallait se concentrer sur les
demandeurs d'emploi en tant que personne
en tant que client
qui cherchent un emploi et qui doit
rapidement trouver un emploi les études
internationales nous montre que plus en
passe du temps dans le statut de
demandeur d'emploi plus il est difficile
d'y retourner par la suite c'est
pourquoi nous nous sommes concentrés
sur les mesures adaptées qui permettent
de requalifier les demandeurs d'emploi
et de les faire réintégrer le marché de
l'emploi plus rapidement
nous avons en allemagne comme nous
l'avons dit mener beaucoup d'évaluation
nous avons par exemple constaté que la
politique du marché de l'emploi active
avec l'objectif de mettre
les demandeurs d'emploi face aux postes
à pourvoir tous ces modalités sont
régulièrement évalués et adapté par
exemple nous avons au cours de l'année
dernière au cours des dernières années
nous avons réduit les mesures des
emplois aidés
puisque nous avons constaté que à partir
du moment où une personne participe à ce
type de programmes d'emplois aidés
cela se passe relativement bien en
revanche ce qui se passe à la fin du
programme de contrats aidés est
assez difficile pour le dire simplement
c'est donc ici que nous avons amélioré
les mesures afin de
d'améliorer la condition générale de
cette évolution donc revenons
à l'année 2005 c'est l'année où était
mise en oeuvre la dernière partie le
dernier chapitre des réformes hartz iv
la question à poser
est la suivante comment s'est développée
le marché de l'emploi selon les
différents secteurs industriels
nous avons observé qu' il y a eu plus de
créations d'emplois dans le secteur des
services nous avons donc tout en bas de
l'échelle l'industrie manufacturière et
l'industrie de production l'allemagne
étant certes célèbre pour son industrie
on voit ici en gris le marché du
bâtiment par exemple
on observe bien que l'augmentation des
emplois est moindre
tout ce que nous avons gagné dans ce
domaine a été annulé par la crise 2009
d'ailleurs donc les améliorations
proviennent plus particulièrement du
secteur des services que ce soit le
commerce la logistique ou encore le
domaine public comme par exemple les
aide à les services à la personne
si l'on
différencie non pas selon les secteurs
mais selon le niveau d'emploi le taux
d'emploi on observe
une grande partie des emplois ont été
sondées emplois à temps partiel
mais parallèlement à cela il y a eu la
création d'emplois à temps plein ce qui
veut dire en somme que toutes les formes
d'emploi
sont croissants
tout en bas de l'échelle on ne voit
uniquement les personnes
employées dans des mini jobs
par ailleurs nous avons représenté ici
les intérimaires le temps
dans le cadre des mesures hearts il a
des rues qui leur est la dérégulation de
ou plutôt la libéralisation
de l'emploi des indemnités a aujourd'hui
atteint le seuil de 1 million
et on résumer nous pouvons dire que
l'augmentation n'a pas été
excédentaire plus que nécessaire il y
avait une augmentation forte au début
mais ça s'est stabilisé par la suite
les emplois à temps déterminé ont
également augmenté surtout depuis les
années 2000 et les mini jobs sont de
plus en plus
pratiqué comme une activité secondaire
et non pas une activité principale
depuis 2005 on peut donc observer qu'il
n'y a aucune forme d'emploi qui a pris
le pas sur une autre
il y avait une autre
réforme très importante du marché du
travail en 2001 cela cette loi porte et
où cette réforme portait sur le lin
production de plus de flexibilité à
travers des contrats à durée déterminée
donc des nouvelles règles pour les
contrats déterminée et le temps partiel
le temps intérimaire pardon le travail
intérimaire
en même temps nous devons sully ni
souligner que nous n'avons pas pour
autant modifier profondément notre loi
du tenant aux lois du travail par
exemple nous n'avons pas touché à la
protection contre les licenciements
économiques
donc il reste nous avons sauvegardé
cet acquis qui reste entre les mains des
partenaires sociaux qui est la
protection contre le licenciement
économique
il
ya une autre question qui
on peut se poser c'est comment on évalue
l'effet positif ou négatif des
évolutions que nous observons
on parle en allemagne d'une d'un type
d'emplois atypiques lorsqu'on parle de
mini jobs temps partiel ou intérimaires
on les appelle un typique puisque c'est
un terme à peu près neutre certains
diront que ce sont des emplois précaires
ce n'est pas tout à fait précis
néanmoins il s'agit d'emplois flexible
mais pas que c'est donc assez hétérogène
quand type d'emploi c'est pourquoi nous
avons choisi le terme emplois atypiques
actuellement on discute notamment le
travail à temps partiel on voit que ce
type d'emploi a augmenté depuis 2009
surtout on voit qu'on que les
entreprises ont recours à ce type
d'emploi ou à ce type de contrat pour
faire face à des fluctuations
conjoncturelles
ceci dans le souci de sauvegarder des
emplois des personnels permanents
très souvent on considère le travail
partiel ou le travail intérimaire comme
une sorte de tremplin pour réintégrer le
marché de l'emploi ce qui est assez vrai
pour une partie des demandeurs d'emploi
mais un peu moins pour les personnes qui
sont encore assez proche des types
d'emplois
conventionnel en somme on peut dire les
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée ou
encore des personnes très peu qualifiés
ont l'occasion à travers des contrats à
durée déterminée de reprendre pied et de
se réhabituer à ce type de travail donc
là nous avons de nouveau introduit des
nous avons introduit des nouvelles
règles qui anticipe même le salaire
minimum de 8 euros 50 désormais nous
discutons de la durée maximale des
contrats à durée déterminée il est
question de limiter ce type de contrat à
18 mois mais jusqu'à maintenant nous
leur avons pas encore suffisamment
d'arguments
les sisyphe
c'est quelque chose qui continue à être
en discussion et qui sera le résultat
des débats politiques en cours
nous pouvons observer
aussi que
le temps le secteur public et dans les
sciences
il y à une augmentation
des contrats à durée déterminée parce
que de nombreux entrants sur le marché
du travail que ce soit des apprentis que
ce soit des stagiaires
commence à travailler par des contrats à
durée déterminée néanmoins le taux de
personnes qui sont ensuite embauché par
un contrat à durée indéterminée sont
assez grands
par ailleurs il faut des arguments bien
précis et fondée pour pouvoir renouveler
les contrats à durée déterminée
puis pour les mini jobs et les contrats
à temps partiel nous savons
qu'ils sont tous qu'ils se situent
pratiquement tous en dessous du seuil de
400 ou 450 euros de rémunération
puisque 450 euros et le seuil au delà
duquel on ne peut plus prétendre aux
allocations de
ce qu'on appelle chômage de en allemagne
nous avons
conduit ses réformes au cours des années
2002 2005
les rémunérations pour les mini jobs ont
été revalorisés en 2004
mais les deux mesure existait auparavant
quand on observe donc c'est que
l'augmentation des emplois à contrat à
temps partiel ou à contre a dû terminer
est une évolution à long terme il n'y a
pas de sot véritablement à observer
on a par exemple le liban faut sauver
une étude qui les conduit de façon
régulière au niveau européen
soulève la question si quelqu'un qui est
en emploi à temps partiel pourrait
prétendre à un poste à temps plein ce
cette question on y répond que le taux
de couverture bilité et éventuellement
de 25% la plupart du temps il faut
néanmoins tenir compte du fait que ce
qu'il s'agit souvent de femmes de
personnes qui ont d'autres occupations
qui veulent s'occuper de la famille etc
qui sont finalement assez
assez satisfait
nous avons
prévu un budget de 4 à 4,5 millions
d'euros
qui couvre
la masse salariale pour les mini jobs
il faut ici également tenir compte des
contextes des ménages un grand nombre
des personnes qui occupent des mini jobs
ne veulent pas de doma d'emploi à taux
plein souvent il s'agit du deuxième de
la deuxième personne active d'un ménage
il s'agit par exemple aussi de retraités
ou des étudiants
néanmoins on peut constater que cette
mesure qui était initialement prévu pour
des demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée
ce groupe cible n'est plus du tout
couverts par ces mesures
et on peut le voir d'un oeil critique
il reste que
c'est un c'est une mesure qui trouvent
des adeptes des deux côtés que ce soit
du côté des employeurs ou du côté des
des employés il faut savoir qu'il s'agit
en même temps d'une subvention fiscale
pour
des personnes qui ont des revenus
relativement conséquents
puisque en se contentant avec un
deuxième revenu au niveau du mini jobs
on évite une trop haute
imposition
un autre aspect très important que nous
devons dans nous devons non dont nous
devons tenir compte et l'évolution des
salaires
là je voudrais laisser de côté un petit
peu la dimension internationale et me
concentrer sur les inégalités des
salaires en allemagne
nous
en place
des différentes
caution avec lesquels nous pouvons
mesurer l'écart des salaires notamment
le caution
djinnit depuis des années 80 nous
appliquons donc cette cette unité de
mesure pour évaluer
l'évolution des salaires
dans la mesure où il y eu une certaine
duffy lord d'une rétention mesure 1 on a
été mesurée dans les demandes
d'augmentation de salaire de ce fait
là les inégalités commencent à
s'égaliser
aujourd'hui nous sommes capables de
mettre
dans les emplois sur le marché du
travail des personnes
qui sont capables de s'y tenir un
certain temps
donc la tendance est
un peu plus positive
et on constate qu'on préfère employer
beaucoup de personnes quitte à
réaliser les inégalités de salaires
il reste que l'état a pour mission
d'intervenir à travers les politiques
fiscales et autres en cas de difficulté
lorsqu'on cherche à établir
le revenu d'un ménage d'une famille
ce don ce que les allemands considèrent
comme le salaire idéal cette somme n'a
pas évolué depuis 2009 et c'est assez
étonnant
même depuis 2005 nous n'avons pas pu
constater de divergence des revenus nets
des familles
en allemagne
pour résumer
le succès que nous pouvons observer la
réussite que nous pouvons observer sur
le marché de l'emploi en allemagne est
en grande partie dû aux réformes
les partenaires sociaux
les employeurs et les employés y ont
contribué à parts égales il y avait à la
fois la
mesure à sion en termes de demande
d'augmentation de salaire
l'introduction de la flexibilité et puis
le temps a fait que au bout de certaines
années ces mesures ont pu porter leurs
fruits
néanmoins nous ne pouvons pas prétendre
nous ne nous n'avons pas les preuves
scientifiques pour affirmer que les
réformes soient uniquement responsables
de ces améliorations
nous avons réussi à augmenter le taux de
participation le taux d'intégration sur
le marché de l'emploi des personnes
difficilement employables
nous avons constaté que ont fait usage
de plus en plus fréquemment de contrats
à temps partiel mais ce n'est pas
forcément quelque chose de critiques
nous avons également admis le fait qu'il
y ait des écarts de salaires
reste à savoir quelles sont les
perspectives
auxquelles doit se préparer le marché de
l'emploi allemand il ya d'une part le
vieillissement de la population
l'évolution démographique
le nombre croissant des retraités
et
les inégalités que l'on observe
aujourd'hui
consiste particulièrement dans le fait
qu'
il n'y a assez peu de mobilité à
l'intérieur du marché du travail
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui trouve un
emploi
modestement payer à beaucoup plus de
difficultés à passer à un emploi bien
payé donc cette mobilité là est moindre
on voit qu'on arrive à
intégrer un certain nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi mais ils restent sur des
emplois avec des niveaux de salaires
relativement stable il y a donc là
moyens d'améliorer les choses i la voie
que nous avons choisie jusqu'à
maintenant
c'est à dire une réforme qui vise à
moderniser le marché du travail et à
améliorer la mise en convergence ou la
mise en
la mise en face de la demande et de
l'offre de l'emploi
c'est le pas suivant serait
de d'évaluer de façon critique les
nouvelles réformes de retraites
néanmoins nous devons pas mettre en
péril les réussites ou les succès que
nous avons pu enregistrer jusqu'à
maintenant mais ce sont peut-être là des
questions que vous avez déjà prévues
pour les changes le pré dès maintenant
donc dans un premier temps je vous
remercie de votre attention et encore
une fois de votre invitation et nous
restons à
disponible pour répondre à vos questions
merci également pour votre présentation
et je vais donc passer la parole à
madame le rapporteur michelle demessine
donc qui va vous posez certainement
merci question je vous remercie pour
votre exposé qui est
très détaillée très intéressant qui nous
permet de de faire le voyage avec vous
de cette stratégie avec les résultats
dont vous parlez il me manque peut-être
et nous manque peut-être deux éléments
enfin en tout cas moi y'en a un qui me
vient immédiatement à l'esprit c'est le
taux d'emploi des femmes
quel était-il avant la réforme
et est-ce que et maintenant est-ce qu'il
a progressé est en tout cas en même
temps combien combien représente dans
les états
les
les emplois atypiques comme vous les
avez est nommé
la part des femmes dans les emplois
atypiques parce qu'il me semble que le
taux de salariat féminin en allemagne
était inférieur à ce que ce que nous
connaissons en france déjà depuis
quelques années et l'aide la deuxième
réflexion que je me fais c'est l'impact
évidemment ces comparatifs et on est
souvent appelée eau à comparer nos deux
pays donc on y réfléchit et le deuxième
élément a peut-être à prendre en compte
et le renouvellement des classes d'âge
c'est à dire que il me semble vous
n'avez pas cité les chiffres alors
peut-être que je me trompe que chaque
année dans votre pays il sort un certain
nombre de
deux personnes qui entrent dans le
marché du travail qui sortent de l'école
pour entrer dans le marché du travail et
elles sont inférieurs à ceux qui
ils sont sortis du marché du travail
pour des raisons de retraite ou est ce
qu'il ya une application aussi de cet
élément dans vos succès puisque
évidemment vous dites ce
on ne sait pas on n'est pas sûr que ce
soit la réforme qui qui donne le succès
je pense qu'il peut peut-être avoir
aussi ces éléments là donc pour revenir
sur
donc sur sur ces mini jobs
et par la multiplication des
travailleurs pauvres en particulier donc
ces femmes qui travaillent à temps
partiel mais qui peut être auparavant
n'était pas du tout dans le marché du
travail la réussite économique de
l'allemagne at elle pas au fond un coût
social élevé est il possible de cons du
coup de cons quantifier les compléments
de revenus apportés à ses salariés via
l'aide sociale et aussi les coûts
induits pour la collectivité qui
évidemment joue un rôle une autre
question
donc on vous avait parlé que l'allemagne
va mettre en place un salaire minimum de
8 aux 50 au 1er janvier 2015 contre 9,53
en france pensez vous qu'il permettra de
résorber justement ces écarts dont vous
avez parlé entre salariés protégés par
les conventions collectives
mais de vous dont vous avez dit aussi en
même temps que leur salaire se tasser un
peu et main d'oeuvre
précaires ou dit atypique
ou que le dualisme du marché du travail
allemand va persister
j'ai trop vite je vais trop vite
excusez moi je m'excuse auprès
d'athlètes crise
mais j'avais oublié dans mon élan
donc quel serait son impact sur l'emploi
et la compétitivité
toujours pour cette salaire minimum
et combien de salariés seront
effectivement concerner au 1er janvier
2015 et les années suivantes et quels
secteurs particulièrement je continue à
poser mes questions
sera plus facile pour amener vos
réponses une quatrième une troisième
question quelles sont les politiques de
l'emploi menée en allemagne mais je
pense que vous avez répondu
vraiment manière assez complète
et donc comment l'utilisation du chômage
partiel at elle permis de limiter les
licenciements pendant la crise donc ça
c'est la période de 2009 dont vous que
vous avez évoqué
pensez vous
que la france alors on demande votre
avis souffre véritablement d'un coût du
travail trop élevée
sans véritable handicap ne tient il pas
plutôt à une compétitivité hors prix
beaucoup moins forte que celle de
l'allemagne
une sixième question
l'allemagne est souvent citée en exemple
pour la qualité de ses filières
d'apprentissage c'est un sujet
qu'on aborde souvent
chez nous parce que
quand les problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés dans ce domaine certains
relèvent de relève les difficultés
auxquelles elles sont aujourd'hui
confrontés c'est à dire que cette forme
d'excellence part et il est plutôt
rencontrent des difficultés
pouvez vous nous parler de ses
difficultés
et est ce qu'il est possible pour la
france
de s'inspirer de votre politique
en matière justement de
filières d'apprentissage
et enfin dernière question
l'allemagne et est confronté vous l'avez
souligné au vieillissement de sa
population
comment
comment va-t-elle faire face
au financement de son système de
protection sociale et en même temps donc
du coup à la hausse des dépenses des
risques vieillesse
e
et maladie avec 1
une courbe de vieillissement
de sa population telles qu'elles se
présentent dans votre pays merci excusez
moi d'avoir été très longue
bien nous allons vous laisser choisir
qui répond à
chacune des questions simplement
j'ajouterai juste une question à celle
de madame le rapporteur dans la mesure
où elle a abordé le sujet des emplois
atypiques
donc
c'est une particularité française mais
vous savez qu'on a on a voté un minimum
maintenant pour les emplois à temps
partiel qui est applicable avoir cédé
1er juillet et où il ne peut pas ne
pourra plus y avoir de temps partiel en
dessous de 24 heures par semaine qu'en
pensez vous une question
voilà est ce que est ce que vous votre
reer quelque chose de semblable chez
vous c'est simplement une remarque
un feeling d'assouan fille de frags
merci c'était beaucoup de caisses
alors je commence tout simplement et
j'espère que
nous allons arriver à répondre à nous
deux à toutes vos questions
alors la première question le taux de
participation des femmes à l'emploi il
faut constater deux choses d'une part
il y à la décision fondamentale des
femmes à savoir bultel s'engager sur le
marché du travail ou non veut-elle
participer et l'autre question quand on
a décidé donc de travailler c'est de
savoir combien d'heures on souhaite
travailler
je dois dire que les deux ont augmenté
le taux de participation des femmes
depuis les dix dernières années
ces femmes travaillent plutôt à temps
partiel et ce nombre-là également
augmenté
parce qu'en 2011 que le sait mais on ne
peut pas
dissocier cela du contexte des
déminages parce que
ces décisions sont prises ensemble au
sein d'un ménage et il s'agit toujours
d'une question économique au final
combien veux-t-on dépensés pour faire
garder ses enfants qui a le salaire le
plus élevé cette personne-là va bien sûr
travailler plus vraisemblablement à
temps complet donc il ya différents
aspects liés à cette décision et
monsieur clermont déjà évoqué la
question disons en principe la majorité
de personnes qui travaillent à temps
partiel sont satisfaites il y en a une
partie qui n'est pas satisfaite il faut
réfléchir à quoi cela est dû mais l'une
des raisons
nommé drôle et souvent qu'on a des
problèmes pour la garde des enfants
c'est un problème qui au
cas l'on s'attaque actuellement en
allemagne de manière assez massif
d'ailleurs mais il est encore trop tôt
pour pouvoir dire si on va régler la
question ou non
depuis dix ans il y à des mesures qui
ont été prises
on a vraiment développer les
possibilités de garde d'enfants il faut
voir comment les choses vont évoluer
donc dans le dans un foyer ce sont des
questions très important et de ce fait
cela concerne les emplois atypiques avec
les mini et midi job il faut voir qu'il
ya beaucoup de
personnes qui recourent
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure vous
savez ces taux de chômage longue durée
ce que l'on appelle chez nous la
location 2 et
on a le droit de travailler avec
lengagne un salaire jusqu'à
450 euros et donc
on essaie de jouer un peu sur tous les
tableaux donc on va travailler jusqu'à
ce que je gagnais les 450 euros et après
ça ne vaut plus la peine de travailler
parce que on est obligé de de payer
certaines certains impôts dans un phare
touche moins
qu'on peut nous avait parlé des
compléments de revenus
en fait ce sont donc des salariés qui
ont besoin de l'aide de la part de
l'état et là il faut distinguer les
personnes
qui
travaillent à temps complet et
il faut voir qu'ils ne peuvent pas vivre
d'après les standards de
la protection sociale minimum ans alors
c'est pour cela que de ce fait on a
quelque part un salaire minimum avec
notre protection sociale minimum ont
défini un niveau de revenu minimum de 6
à 7 euros de l'heure de selon l'endroit
où l'on vit ça dépend des coûts du
logement etc selon les régions
pluvieuses le dos combien y at-il de
personnes sont mille cent cinquante
mille
cent vingt-cinq mille personnes qui sont
seule leur salaire dans un foyer et qui
ont besoin des aides en plus malgré le
fait qu'elle travaille à plein temps
en général on reçoit aussi des
allocations en raison du contexte
familial parce qu'on a une femme parce
qu'on a un de plusieurs enfants
on a droit à ces compléments
de revenus le marché du travail ne peut
pas payer en fonction du nombre de
personnes que l'on à nourrir dans un
foyer et donc c'est l'état qui par un
système de transfert et un système
fiscal
rétabli ici même les disparités donc le
système social et fiscal est responsable
et doit assurer ce qui est acceptable
enfin ce qui est le minimum acceptable
et si ce n'est pas possible d'avoir ce
minimum par le marché de l'emploi c'est
l'état qui compense
et donc pour les personnes qui
travaillent à temps complet
de stream
le problème qu'ils reçoivent et des
compléments de revenus c'est vraiment
extrêmement nous minimum
la majeure partie des personnes qui vont
vraiment elle cumule et certains
avantages ce sont par exemple alors il
est fan qui élèvent seules leurs enfants
l on a des enfants les élèves seuls
on ne sait pas exactement
on n'a pas assez d'éléments de preuve
mais est-ce qu'elles le font
volontairement de travailler à temps
partiel et ou de travailler pour 75% du
temps et le reste d'avoir donc un
complément de revenu parce qu'elle va le
garder du temps pour rester avec leurs
enfants ou est-ce qu'elles sont obligées
d'accepter des emplois à temps partiel
parce qu'elles n'ont pas de système de
garde pour leurs enfants ça nous ne le
savons pas ça veut dire qu'une grande
partie de cette aide sociale une notre
système s'est vraiment de garantir un
minimum à toutes les personnes qui ont
des besoins et qui sont dans la
nécessité en tomate mais avec ce 6 annie
parce que nous sommes et rita social
nous avons automatiquement c est de là
et le chant le salaire minimum ou n'y
change rien parce que nous on a vraiment
un système de protection
sociale minimum qui lui n'est pas de 6 à
7 euros de l'heure pour les familles
je fus vous pour les familles pour une
mère ou un père qui élève seul ses
enfants on a des parents isolés on a
vraiment des taupes usé les gens
et là il faut vraiment garder il faut en
fait il faut gagner la 12 à 14 euros par
heure et le salaire minimum ne va rien
changer à cette situation va donc dans
notre système établi en allemagne
en fait c'est bizarre notre duire ainsi
le salaire minimum parce qu'en fait nous
nous avions notre système de protection
sociale minimum donc ça existait déjà il
aurait été mieux avisée mais bon
maintenant ce n'est pas l'avis officiel
du conseil allemand des experts
économiques mais si on avait voulu
rester dans notre logique il aurait été
plus sensé
de soumah de rendre explicite ce salaire
minimum
que l'on n'a implicitement par notre
protection sociale minimum
et de le proposer comme un salaire c'est
6 à 7 euros dont je parlais selon les
régions de le déclarer explicitement
comme un salaire
tout est content parce que si on tant
que chômeur
je pense que ça va me faire du bien de
travailler pour un moindre salaire
pendant deux ou trois mois
certes je peux travailler
moi mais si je ne veux pas je ne suis
pas sanctionné dans cette logique là il
aurait été plus intéressant
d'avoir un salaire d'avoir ce système là
quand même système comme salaire minimum
parce qu'il ne changera rien la
problématique des compléments de revenus
apportés aux salariés
j'aimerais est complétée brièvement en
ce qui concerne donc ces personnes qui
pensent que l'on a essayé des
travailleurs dont ils dépendent de
l'aide sociale on a essayé des salaires
des modèles de salaire qu'on appelle
nous combiné
à savoir que l'aide sociale est à est
couplée
au fait qu'il faut également s'investir
personnellement
même si c'est relativement difficile
ce système de salaire combiné ne
fonctionne pas trop bien mais une des
questions déterminantes est vraiment de
savoir quelle est la situation
si
si une personne ne peut travailler
qu'avec un certain salaire quel qu'il
soit
s'il est trop il ville
cette personne ne va pas
sortir de l'aide sociale elle va tomber
directement dans notre système de
protection sociale minimum c'est
difficile de savoir
comment gérer la chose mais quelle est
l'alternative c'est ce qu'il faut se
demander
et
sur ce qui concerne les emplois
atypiques pour les femmes si je ne me
trompe pas au niveau du taux de
participation des femmes nous sommes
relativement mieux placés en europe je
crois maintenant mais vous avez bien sûr
justement remarquer quand une grosse
partie il s'agit d'emplois à temps
partiel
ce dont il faut tenir compte c'est
également l'évolution démographique chez
nous on boit que
parallèlement la génération des baby
boom
il ya des personnes qui se sont retirés
temporairement du marché et qui
reviennent dans que le potentiel de
personnes actives
et puis également avec les migrants un
fait que l'on a donc à une évolution
et beaucoup de personnes souhaitent
travailler à temps partiel pour des
raisons
lié à l'intérêt de leur ménage
après
et on voit bien des différences quand
ans quand on s'interroge sur le fait de
savoir si les travailleurs à temps
partiel souhaite travailler à temps
complet on voit une différence entre les
hommes et les femmes et puis ya aussi
des différences culturelles en allemagne
de l'est par exemple
on trouve plus de femmes qui recherchent
des emplois à temps complet quand l'ex
allemagne de l'ouest
je trouve
qu explique un certain nombre de choses
de votre système c'est que justement la
question des femmes de l'est l'expliquer
elle était beaucoup plus à intégrer dans
le travail de manière
dans le marché générale du travail dgt
de manière à égalité avec les hommes
mais on peut parler un petit peu de
comme cela qu'elle avait
elle avait accès au travail
et on trouvait un taux d'emploi féminin
en allemagne de l'est qui était quand
même assez important c'est la même chose
en france dire que
toute l'explication que vous apportez
sur les femmes choisissent de travailler
selon la condition familiale
en relation avec les enfants à la notion
de ménage que vous évoquez a à plusieurs
reprises ça c'est une situation que nous
avons connue en france d'une et d'une
évolution il ya près de 40 ans est
d'ailleurs on appelait ça le salaire
d'appoint les femmes entrées tout
doucement sur le marché du travail mais
avec cette notion de salaire d'appoint
c'est à dire pas pas être salarié à part
entière et être autonome et à voir
l'autonomie de par son travail parce que
évidemment lorsque dans le couple c'est
comme une notion très importante
lorsque dans le couple il y a le mari
qui a un salaire
à temps plein fin salaire à temps plein
et que les pousse à un salaire à temps
partiel il n'y a pas égalité
égalité dans le ménage au nouveau au
niveau de l'autonomie personnelle et
donc c'est très très lié aux aspirations
des femmes en général et c'est vrai
qu'en allemagne et cette notion de
il ya 40 ans cette notion de travail des
femmes elle se présentait pas du tout la
même façon qu'en france et avait très
peu de femmes qui a accédé au
travail au marché du travail à un taux
beaucoup plus faible
peut-être une courte réponse
en tant qu'économiste je pars du
principe que les personnes prennent des
décisions
ce qui veut dire que le contexte
familial peut induire une décision je
pense qu'on ne peut pas vraiment dire
que le taux d'emploi des femmes doit
devenir un objectif politique les pompes
à titre d'économiste cela ne fait pas
vraiment 200 ce moment
mais je pense qu'il doit exister la
possibilité de décider si oui ou non on
cherche un emploi à temps partiel ou en
temps à un emploi à temps complet
et il faut que la femme et la
possibilité de décider tout autant qu'un
homme pour savoir combien d'heures ils
souhaitent travailler par semaine
et c'est un point sur lequel l'allemagne
et travail relativement intensément
depuis les dix dernières années
notamment dans le souci d'équilibrer la
vie de travail et la vie privée
et cela a pour conséquence des décisions
telles que nous les avons observés
alors que c'est vraiment là le moment
décisif et non pas uniquement le mode de
garde d'enfants tu meures prendre
autrement ce que vous êtes en train de
nous dire quelque part enfin c'est comme
ça que je le dis vous estimez que
le salaire minimum
qui va qui arrive donc et qui se
substitue quelque part chez vous à une
us notion de ressources minimum parce
qu'avant vous aviez des ressources
minimum c'est-à-dire pour ajouter à la
partie solaire une protection sociale
qui étaient apportés par l'état et non
par l'entreprise ou du moins non par le
travail un peu ça et est ce que quelque
part vous êtes en train de nous dire que
finalement l'introduction du salaire
minimum répondra
moins finement aux besoins et aux choix
des personnes que ne répondait
l'ancienne formule quelque part du
revenu en fin de la ressource minimum
je ne sais pas si je me fais bien
comprendre parce que moi je comprends
cela un peu comme ça vous dit de toute
façon nous n'avons pas besoin de salaire
minimum puisque de toute façon nous quel
que soit le salaire que perçoit la
personne il y a une contrepartie d'un
système social qui est apporté une
réponse par l'état et donc il va très
largement se substituer je veux dire à
ce qu'on appelle maintenant le salaire
minimum qui va arriver mais simplement
les jeux ça répondra pas forcément aussi
bien aux choix des personnes
c'est comme ça que je lis mais je sais
pas peut-être
peut-être pour l'illustrer sur un
exemple prenons quelqu'un qui travaille
pour 7 euros 50 de l'heure actuelle
peut-être ils demandent les accueils
allocations chômage supplémentaire les
cibles que s'il peut les obtenir ou non
mais ça ça dépend du contexte familial
comme je voulais
désormais on lui dit vroon le nôtre doit
désormais travailler à 8h50 il sera
content from et 600 emplois ce maire est
perdu pour autant et qu'il retombe dans
le sous-sol dans le système social d
assurance chômage il ne serait pas
particulièrement ravis donc si nous
devions introduire un seuil inférieur en
deçà duquel on n'a pas le droit de
travailler ce serait autre chose
ce que nous faisons désormais pour
l'allemagne dans son ensemble une vigne
de productivité c'est quelque chose que
nous pouvons observer également sur le
taux de productivité qui se
différencient entre la partie ouest et
la partie est de l'allemagne
mais même région dans la plupart des
régions en bavière bade wurtemberg où en
rhénanie westphalie nord j'espère le
salaire minimum ou ne pose aucun
problème
mais il pose un problème dans les
régions où à la fois la produit le taux
de productivité et et le niveau de prix
et bars et c'est le cas dans les pays
dans les régions rurales de l'est lors
de l'introduction du salaire minimum
si on ne met en rapport avec ce que je
peux acheter avec mon pouvoir d'achat il
est bien plus élevé mais au mecklembourg
poméranie métaux lourds que on va bien
si je par exemple j'ai un revenu de 10
euros en bavière je peux acheter au
moins deux choses
ou de funk 26%
désormais il faut aussi savoir que où la
houle de face au fil à retordre le taux
d'emploi dans ce classement d'allemagne
de l'est est inférieur à 25 % environ du
taux d'emploi en allemagne de l'ouest en
prendre qu avec l'introduction du
salaire minimum un certain nombre
d'emplois
n'existeront plus
nous avons en allemagne l'acquis social
de 7
de ce revenu social
et finalement avec l'introduction du
salaire minimum à 8 euros 50 on prend ce
risque là
vous avez tout à leur poser la question
du nombre de personnes concernées et
quel type de personne on part 2 5
millions de personnes
qui travaillent actuellement en dessin
du salaire minimum ce sont des personnes
plutôt en allemagne de l'est plutôt des
femmes que des hommes plutôt des
personnes qui travaillent à temps
partiel et dans des secteurs très
spécifiques par exemple la restauration
un petit peu la com est un petit peu le
commerce un petit peu les services à la
personne ou encore dans les entreprises
dites sociales comme lorsqu'on combine
lorsqu'on rend tout ces facteurs
on peut constater que le salaire minimum
se situe aux deux au delà du salaire
médian en allemagne de l'est
donc en tant que
expérience politique ou expérimentations
politiques c'est un peu le risque et
c'est ça peut avoir un effet de choc
dans certaines régions
ont peut-être en complément pour
éclaircir nos propos lorsque je parle de
notre système social et que je parle de
ce type d'allocation chômage de
ainsi que 2 du revenu vital minimum
c'est quelque chose comme un salaire
minimum implicite au même sens que cela
s'appelle comme ça et ça devenait
ministre est dans l'ensemble le
colombier votre art danse du point de
vue d'un économiste je pense que on
préfère toujours pouvoir dire que le
travail peu importe le montant du
salaire que tout que de dire je vie du
minimum social je ne parle même pas des
effets psychologiques que peut avoir le
chômage automates
quelque chose c'est pour ça que nous
parlons d'un salaire minimum implicite
et je ne voudrais pas que vous me
preniez a à ce sujet je ne suis pas en
train de plaider pour introduire plus de
personnes dans le système social
ce que je voulais dire c'est que à
travers notre système social nous avons
implicitement déjà quelque chose qui
correspondrait à un salaire minimum de
temps et surtout ils n'ont pas ces deux
mesures n'ont pas le même effet est ce
que vous pouvez
le salaire minimum implicite avec les
les
le les sciences sociales est ce que vous
pouvez plus de détails et parce que j'ai
bien compris que vous avez dit qu'il
était
en fonction d'un certain nombre de
critères de taille de famille etc mais
on n'en voit pas très bien comment ça
fonctionne
lorsque vous percevez la location de
revenu minimum vital c'est une somme qui
s'élève à environ 480 12 mois pour une
personne 392 euros par personne
célibataire c'est un chiffre qui est
calculé en fonction du panier moyen et
qui dépend aussi de la région dans
laquelle vous habitez vous ne pouvez pas
partir du principe que tout le monde en
allemagne il perçoit les mêmes
allocations minimales de minimum vital
il peut y avoir des différences de
plusieurs euros
donc les prestations payées par
l'assurance sociale sont très
différentes vilmunen ici en tant que
célibataire je perçois mène
au total environ 700 euros je peux très
bien faire mon calcul afin d'établir le
salaire brut que je devrai gagner pour
avoir le même la même somme nette c'est
pour ça que nous parlons d'un salaire
minimum implicite
en étant en allant travailler je
souhaiterais gagner plus que ce
revenu minimum
par ailleurs nous partons du principe
que quoi qu'il arrive il est préférable
de pouvoir travailler plutôt que de
percevoir des prestations sociales
il faut veiller à ce que les incitations
et d'aller travailler soient
suffisamment importantes
c'est pour ça qu'il est important de
comparer les revenus sociales vitales ou
minima avec les salaires minimum qu'on
peut percevoir il faut que cela
n'empêche pas l'envi d'aller travailler
c'est
le fait sur lequel je souhaitais attirer
votre attention
c'est que pour certains groupes bien
ciblés on peut partir du principe que
le salaire minimum est implicite mais
pour une famille à peu près de quatre
personnes le revenu minimum vital
s'élève déjà à 1800 1900 euros par mois
et ce n'est pas évident d'obtenir ce
type de salaire c'est tôt ce montant de
salaire
d'un vaste cour bref vous aviez
également parlé du chômage partiel
le chômage partiel est un instrument
conjoncturel
crises auxquelles on a eu recours et qui
a bien fonctionné au cours de la
dernière crise mais au
sein de notre conseil allemand des
experts économiques nous disons toujours
attention ce n'est pas un remède miracle
pour toutes les crises de l'emploi
de la demande avait beaucoup
diminuer la demande internationale pour
les biens produits en allemagne au
moment de la crise mais ensuite elle est
revenue très fortement ça veut dire que
après la crise on nous a demandé le même
portefeuille de produits que celui qu'on
nous demandait avant la crise
mais si on avait eu une crise
structurelle
personne ne voudrait plus acheter de
voiture allemands par exemple pour
quelques raisons que ce soit alors là on
aurait une vraie crise pour l'industrie
automobile hélas la demande ne
reviendrait pas et là le chômage partiel
est vraiment un mauvais instrument parce
que on garde l'emploi et au sein des
entreprises dit on
rate un peu le train pour évoluer et
saisir l'occasion d'aller dans vers de
nouvelles filières donc
ça ne fonctionne pas toujours
ç'a fonctionné pour une crise économique
mais il ya beaucoup de créer pendant
lesquelles le recours au chômage partiel
ne ferait qu'empirer la solution et cela
coûte beaucoup
l'allemagne a dépensé beaucoup d'argent
pour cela et si vraiment la crise avait
remis en question notre structure
économique
on aurait dépensé tout cet argent et
cela nous aurait manqué pour notre
transformation pour notre changement
structurel après donc je tiens à dire
que ce n'est pas un remède miracle qu'il
faut investir à chaque il faut appliquer
à chaque fois d'ailleurs j'aimerais
compliqué en demies compliqué en 2009
chômage partiel
avait contribué bien mais gérer la crise
mais quand même il n'était pas tout seul
il y avait d'autres spécificités du
système allemand on ad on avait négocié
avec les salariés détériore des
entreprises des comptes de temps de
travail
et pour maintenir l'emploi et on de
réduisant donc
le temps de travail pendant une certaine
durée jusqu'à ce que on est à nouveau de
l'emploi alors proposées et c'est encore
une question qui à l'ordre du jour
savoir s'il faut limiter la durée de ses
comptes
de temps de travail
donc il faut en fait les éliminer assez
rapidement ne pas les garder pendant une
trop longue durée
mais là il s'agit vraiment du jeu libre
jeu
du marché entre les partenaires sociaux
sans que l'état n'intervienne
ce qui concerne les problèmes
structurels il y à différents
constructeurs
allemands il y en a qui ont eu quelques
difficultés ces dernières années
constructeur automobile il y en a qui
ont également eu recours au chômage
partiel pendant un certain temps mais
deux ans plus tard ils ont quand même
pas pu échapper à la restructuration
ce sont les problèmes quand on n'a pas
simplement un problème temporaire et
conjoncturel mais vraiment un problème
structurel
maintenant je me vient à votre première
question comment est-ce qu'on
trets et si ces coûts de système social
annonce je vous avais dit au départ que
nous avions au départ un taux de chômage
très élevé auprès des 5 millions en ce
moment et cela bien sûr a eu des coûts
fiscaux très élevé les coûts budget ne
va pas un fils comme et budgétaire pour
l'état il fallait
trouver des aides pour ceux qui
travaillait plus pour ceux qui ne
travaillaient pas donc on avait vraiment
beaucoup de personnes qui avaient besoin
d'une aide et de ce transfert
c'est quoi une tellement augmenté en se
jetant sous un train
ensuite ils ont eu un impact sur les
finances
sinon regardez les tags finances
publiques et leur évolution au dessous
de même fait que le rapport à
l'évolution avant les réformes
que
vinny gars on a
dû payer
tandis que 5% de moins du produit
intérieur brut du pib je parte parce
qu'on a réussi donc à trouver une autre
forme c'est une manière de consolider
également le marché de l'emploi
le ménageant à la fois notre protection
sociale minimum il ne s'agit pas de
diminuer le niveau social il s'agit
juste de trouver des primes d un prêt
pour que les personnes
ce soit active
travaille
cela permet ensuite à moyen terme
d'alléger un peu le budget de l'état
nous y avons relativement bien réussi
vont la démographie c'est un autre
problème est là aussi
les cotisations d'assurance sociale en
allemagne ont considérablement diminué
après avoir atteint leur seuil leurs
records historiques
les cotisations retraites
sont un niveau historiquement bas
aujourd'hui
l'assurance chômage on a un niveau
relativement bas du nuage produit
financier qui est financé plus ou moins
de manière structurelle on a un niveau
de cotisation pour la cotisation chômage
pour la première partie de ces aides
dont je vous ai parlé jusqu'à 24 mois et
ça c'est financé de manière structurelle
plus ou moins on peut en discuter ou
même il ya des
oubliés aux fluctuations normales de
l'économique de l'économie mais on peut
dire que les charges afférentes ont
diminué parce
sociale et c'est l'une des raisons qui
explique la réussite de cette réforme
c'est à dire
de les diminuer cette pression par les
systèmes sociaux parce que sinon on
était dans une spirale
quand on avait de plus en plus de
personnes dans le système qu'il fallait
aider il fallait sans cesse augmenter
les cotisations et cela avait bien sûr
une mauvaise répercussions sur
l'évolution économique
donc il faut bien sûr
arriver à voir transferts et c'est plus
facile quand il ya plus de personnes sur
le marché du travail que l' inverse
vous saviez également demandé si j'ai
bien compris
seniors
que vrac messali demande et donc
avec le
vieillissement de la population
vous avez parlé du fait que l'on avait
puisse donc temps que deux
d'entre eux sautant sur le marché du
travail mais en fait
dire qu'on a un peu une pause dans
l'évolution démographique
on rentre on passe à une autre à la
retraite enfin on a eu on a peu de
personnes qui partent à la retraite
parce que ça correspond aux personnes
qui étaient nés dans les années il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de seins toute
décence
ça va changer bien sûr et ensuite ça va
vraiment vraiment augmenter jusqu'à 2030
d'un moment d'un côté
pour l'instant la situation relativement
détendus pour les plus jeunes qui
arrivent sur le marché
c'est à dire qu'il ya moins par exemple
de jeunes allemands de l'est qui sont
obligés de partir de chez eux pour aller
suivre une formation à l'ouest parce que
il y a suffisamment de places
d'apprentissage à l'est
actuellement mais d'un autre côté
la participation des seniors a beaucoup
augmenté ces dernières on était moins de
50% avant les réformes maintenant on est
à plus de 60% pour un groupe de
personnes qui gagnent quand même
relativement bien donc c'est assez
considérable
des défis que nous aurons réglé
quand toutes ces personnes vont quitter
le marché de l'emploi
il est vrai qu'on ne sait pas s'il notre
financement à long terme que l'on
voulait vraiment assuré avec ces
réformes pourra vraiment
tenir la route et il y a beaucoup de
deux faits d'il y à l'évolution
démographique que l'on peut pas
confirmant prévoir l'instant
il y à aussi la question des aides pour
la garde des enfants
si on arrive à améliorer cela on aura
plus de femmes qui vont qui auront
peut-être un qui auront suivi des études
qui auront aussi d'autres aspirations
peut-être que la génération précédente
et qui voudront peut-être revenir plus
rapidement sur le marché de l'emploi
après avoir eu des enfants et à plein
temps donc peut-être qu'on pourra
compenser un peu si par cela mais il va
falloir du temps mais ce sont des
ajustements automatiques là quand on se
donne les moyens en tant qu'institution
mais pour
l'heure
bon c'était pas forcément en
danger
tout étant également les héros non
structurelles alors il ya les
institutions comment s'organiser il y a
les attraits les primes d'incitation il
y à la demande sur le marché du travail
il y a également les chercheurs d'emploi
il y a ceux qui cherchent des salariés
il faut arriver donc un lit et mixe
trouver une adéquation entre ces
personnes là mais ce qu'il faut c'est
stabilisé les systèmes sociaux quand on
pense au prochain vieillissement de la
population jeu
qui est clair c'est
justifié on a réussi à stabiliser le
tout avec nous aux réformes de la
retraite
16 ans va être stabilisé jusqu'à 2030 si
avec le processus plus ou moins
prévisible grâce à nos réformes
la question c'est qu'est ce qui va se
passer après ce procès c'est 2030 et la
le processus n'est pas terminé
on va perdre beaucoup de population
active
la perte sera plus importante que la
baisse est de là
l'association et c'est une des questions
sur lesquelles il faut nous pencher à
l'avenir comment l or noir iv à avoir le
plus de personnes possible sur le marché
de l'emploi pour pouvoir faire face aux
obligations que nous avons du système
social faisons parce que
le chômage on peut essayer de lutter
avec des réformes structurelles on peut
essayer de le réduire mais
par contre on ne peut pas éviter que les
personnes partent à la retraite
également avoir leur droit à une
retraite elle les auront acquis et la
question c'est comment allons nous
arriver à répondre à ces demandes ça
c'est ma génération comme moi je serai à
la retraite en
2004 je me demande bien ce que je vais
pouvoir encore touché comme retraite du
groupe voilà ce sont les grands défis
d'aujourd'hui
donc nous réforme du marché du travail
sont qu'un petit extrait de ce qui s'est
passé au cours des dix à quinze
dernières années être une question que à
laquelle vous ne peut-être pas répondu
de madame la rapporteure c'était sur la
qualité de votre apprentissage quel est
l'atout que ça a pu constituer dans
l'eure dans le
renouveau allemand si j'ose dire
john ging il est muté mais je voudrais
dire quelque chose en introduction
l'allemagne allait mal aussi les
deux formations en alternance
bien que nous ayons eu ce système cela
ne nous a pas protégés
d'un certain nombre de problèmes on ne
peut pas dire que nous sommes là où nous
sommes parce que nous avons eu ce
système de formation en alternance en
revanche ce qu'on peut dire ce système
permet de diminuer le chômage des jeunes
est dans l'évolution dans le temps cela
influe aussi sur
le marché du travail plus il ya de
personnes qui sont formés le qualifier
plus ils sont incroyables entre
guillemets de façon universelle sur le
marché du travail
donc on peut dire dans l'ensemble cela
contribue à une meilleure qualification
des travailleurs
mais c'est assez difficile à
appliquer sur d'autres pays comme modèle
puisqu'il faut à la fois un consensus
économique et social qui s'est
développée en allemagne au cours des 150
ou 200 dernières années cela n'a pas
toujours été aussi clair il y a eu des
périodes dans lesquels on a considéré
que le système de formation règlement
n'était pas bon au moment où nous avons
réfléchi aux réformes beaucoup pensaient
que ces difficultés étaient dues à un
système de formation insuffisant mais
désormais on considère que cela fait
partie de notre tissu économique que de
former des jeunes de qualifier des
jeunes à travers ce système en deux
formations en alternance et qui améliore
la situation de marché de l'emploi donc
qu'en ce qui concerne la france
et nous avons également évoqué les
différentes institutions européennes
dans notre rappeur européen dans notre
rapport annuel
nous n'avons pas abordé ces sujets pour
donner des leçons à d'autres pays on ne
va être au contraire nous cherchons à
les mettre en garde cosmos concret il
n'est pas évident
de donner des indications bien concrète
on peut dire que des réformes sont
nécessaires
dans certains pays néanmoins la forme
des réformes la façon dont les réformes
seront amenés dépendent des institutions
nationales donc il est important de
savoir quelle est la position des
institutions qui remonte à l'achat qui
ont à charge de mettre en place les
réformes on ne peut pas dire qu'il ya un
système qui est bon définitivement et
n'importe quel autre pays puisse
l'appliquer il faut tenir compte des
contextes culturels et nationales
puisque ce sont les institutions
nationales qui savent le mieux quand
comment mener les réformes nous pouvons
donc en aucun cas émettre des
recommandations comment procéder en
france on voit bien que le chômage des
jeunes est élevé que le taux de chômage
général est élevé il faut bien sûr
s'interroger quelles sont les raisons à
cette situation donne mon opinion
personnelle je répondrais c'est
peut-être le salaire minimum mais ce
n'est pas à moi de le dire c'est là
c'est la recherche ce sont des études
françaises qu'ils doivent établir les
raisons de cette situation
mais ce que nous pouvons observer c'est
qu'elles sont des problèmes et nous
pouvons néanmoins dire qu'il faut faire
des réformes en france puisque ce sont
des problèmes qui ont la même envergure
que nous avons connue en allemagne
face à des problèmes de cette envergure
des réponses sont indispensables mais
comment les comment les dessiner comment
les mener ce ne sont donnés ce ne sont
que les des experts nationaux qui
peuvent le dire
donc merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation qui est la réponse à vos
questions qui je crois nous il a
beaucoup apporté puisque je crois que
c'était intéressant d'avoir votre avis
l'organisme objectif et indépendant
merci beaucoup merci d'être beau
beaucoup d'être venu à cette invitation
sinon plus
voilà pour cette audition de deux
représentants du conseil allemand des
experts économiques un organisme
indépendant qui conseille les décideurs
outre-rhin mais qui vous l'avez vu
marquer son indépendance en ne se
privant pas de critiquer la politique
économique allemande pouvait toujours
voir et revoir toutes les auditions sur
notre site sur publicsenat.fr prochain
rendez vous de l'actualité parlementaire
à 19h pour 24 heures sénat très bonne
journée sur la chaîne parlementaire